remember in 1993 the Dow was at 3,400
Brendan was just heading off to college
I was probably learning to ride a bike
well there was one commercial that year
that none of us can forget and that was
the Vienna Wood dancing be one of my
all-time favorites all right now let's
make that random call with today's
$10,000 question it's a tough one who
shot Alexander Hamilton and that famous
duel
got milk well despite the campaign
success fewer and fewer Americans have
been drinking the white stuff or at
least the old-fashioned dairy lactose
white stuff the market for cow's milk is
shrinking in the US but demand for
value-added milk is booming in now
coca-cola is getting into the game with
fair life this is interesting because
Coke reports the results later on this
morning around 738 I'm the president of
Coke America thinks that fair life can
quote unquote rain money a couple of
concerns though the first one is that
the dairy market in the US is very
fragmented people don't actually buy
store-brand milk is like gasoline
people aren't brand sensitive about like
you drink or is this about their putting
stuff in milk they're putting Stephanie
this is regular like this is let's talk
about what fair life is what is it it is
a brand name and I sort of felt like it
creates a revulsion in me the idea of
fair life and so it's it's it's lactose
free it's got less sugar than regular
milk and it's got extra stuff in it so
it's like super awesome you you say
stuff it has less sugar it was extra
protein extra calcium a lot of parents
might think that sounds good so listen
the dairy industry is fragmented and in
decline but Coke is hoping that it's
marketing prowess can turn that around
but that's exactly what it's it's
marketing prowess but also its
distribution channels Coke has a problem
in which it has distribution channels
all over the world it can really get any
liquid at once anywhere in the world and
the problem is the liquid it's used to
selling nobody wants yours ontraport
from Wells Fargo which just destroys the
past of coke that bubbly is gone
bubbly is gone there is no growth in
carbonated beverages carbonated
beverages in fact in the u.s. are in a
state of structural decline you can
think of it as vitamin water they're
trying to add value and up the price the
price is the other big concern here
people are pretty sensitive to the price
of milk a gallon of fair life I believe
is three dollars and sixty nine cents
for a quart of it I should say that
compares to about low two dollar range
for right insurance no I don't know I
mean I haven't seen it in the store for
starters would you keep morale JP Morgan
was would you buy this stuff I gotta be
honest I'm a little bit more of kind of
an organic shopper than
then it added a to my drinks type of gal
I like to go a little bit more on the
pure research you know the almond milk
like what you drink right yes so
plant-based milks are growing
exponentially literally so I'm talking
soy milk almond milk those kinds of
thing there you can see us milk
alternative sales on the rise look at
that it's a nearly a two billion dollar
industry series and all of those milks
cost a lot more than cow's milk
Kate Moore's point is really interesting
because I mean it goes to a point that
Olivia made earlier in the story meeting
today which is that you know cokes
trying to jump onto this trend of
healthier milks I'm completely missing
what's actually going on which is what
people want more natural we do so much
milk in our we don't do three glasses a
day we've still got an 18 month old
who's drinking a lot of milk but we're
my wife and we drink almond is that's
where the growth is infant formula yeah
another area coke is branching out I
would know all right